warum war es so schwer schwere waffen an
die schwer gebeutelte ukraine zu liefern
die politischen schwergewichte in ampel
koalition und opposition hatten sich
verhakt es kam zu innenpolitischen
meinungsschlacht doch plötzlich geht die
regierung mit einer lösungen die wieder
mal erstaunte öffentlichkeit
schwere waffen für die ukraine koalition
unter druck jetzt in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst zugeschaltete marie agnes
strack zimmermann fdp
bundestagsabgeordnete und vorsitzende
des verteidigungsausschusses
unseres parlaments eben von zugeschaltet
johann wadephul von der cdu außen und
verteidigungsexperte im bundestag und
dort stellvertretender vorsitzender der
unions-fraktion im studio begrüße ich
anton hofreiter bündnis 90 die grünen
sie sind auch ausschussvorsitzender und
zwar des europa-ausschusses im bundestag
ralf stegner auch bundestagsabgeordneter
mal keine ausschussvorsitzender aber
mitglied im sehr wichtigen auswärtigen
ausschuss besteht ja jetzt werden doch
die taten über das ukrainische
schlachtfeld rollen da sind deutsche
flugabwehr pansa hochglanz technik sehr
effektiv beugt sich die spd da mal
wieder den sicherheitspolitischen
realitäten gestern noch hat ihre
parteichefin er gesagt schwere waffen an
die ukraine unter handelt es sich um
schwere waffen seien eigentlich kein
thema na ja also es schwerer waffen sind
was ich gelernt habe wenn kein experte
kein
militärischer begriff sodass geht darum
der ukraine dabei zu helfen sich zu
verteidigen
es geht um flugabwehrwaffen
offenkundig und wir haben die devise
dass wir alles tun was wir verantworten
können um die ukraine zu unterstützen
dass wir zweitens dass nur im bündnis
gemeinsam tun und dann gemeinsam
entscheiden unseren bündnispartnern das
ist hier der fall und insofern hat der
bundessicherheitsrat das entschieden und
das ist heute mitgeteilt worden das
erstaunen in der öffentlichkeit hat ja
manchmal auch ein bisschen mit der
diskussions art zu tun und da sind viele
begriffe wie ankershoffen
verteidigungswaffen schwerer waffen
nicht schwerer waffen sei jedenfalls
nicht so dass sie präzise beschreiben
würden warum wir reden aber offenbar ist
ja nicht nur die öffentlichkeit erstaunt
gewesen heute morgen noch haben der
fraktionsvorsitzende der spd rolf
mützenich und auch der generalsekretär
kevin kühnert in fernsehinterviews sich
gegen diese schweren waffen wenn jetzt
im griff ausgesprochen da war aber
offenbar schon das gegenteil entschieden
sind sie auch überrollt worden von
dieser entscheidung für richtig über
ruhig da nochmal ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass das der wirklich
schwerer waffen gefallen ist soll das
geht um die frage dass die ukraine sich
verteidigen kann aber ich lerne ja ganz
viel darüber dass es enorm viele
militärexperten in jüngster zeit gibt
die in militärischen fragen expertise
haben ich habe ehrlich gesagt nicht
glaube auch nicht dass er die themen auf
militärischen verhängen sollten
jedenfalls ist eine entscheidung die
getroffen worden ist um der ukraine zu
helfen gemeinsam mit dem bündnis im un
sicherheitsrat entschieden und nicht
nach meiner einschätzung ist nicht auf
druck von irgendwelchen anträgen oder
interviews oder anderen dingen von denen
ich gehört habe hofreiter jetzt ist der
begriff schwere waffen nun mal in der
welt da wissen wir auch wovon wir reden
es stehen ja noch 100 schützenpanzer
marder und
88 kampfpanzer leopard 1 auf dem hof
einer deutschen rüstungsfirma schicken
der die jetzt auch noch hinterher in die
ukraine ich halte es für sinnvoll dass
wirklich und ukraine unterstützen wo wir
können denn meine große sorge ist dass
in russland so weiter macht dass sich
der krieg ausweitet wir sehen bereits
jetzt probleme in der republik moldau
und transnistrien
explosionen da stehen bereits russische
soldaten neben der abtrünnigen republik
transnistrien und deshalb ich wie gesagt
all die sorgen total dass sich dieser
krieg ausweitet und wir müssen sehr
genau darauf achten dass wir nicht
direkt kriegspartei werden aber wir
müssen gleichzeitig dafür sorgen dass
die ukraine bestehen kann denn sie
verteidigt hat demokratie und freiheit
für uns alle und insbesondere für die
direkten nachbarn und deshalb glaube ich
müssen wir dort das tun was notwendig
ist stellt zimmermann der fdp-parteitag
letztes wochenende der hat ja
beschlossen dass deutschland nicht
kriegspartei werten darf das was anton
hofreiter gerade auch gesagt hat nun ist
das zunächst mal ein parteitagsbeschluss
da gibt es auch immer viele beschlüsse
aber inwieweit stecken wir denn jetzt
gerade durch die jüngsten entscheidungen
was diese waffensysteme angeht
eigentlich
in diesem krieg schon drin
also das ist keine entscheidung des
parteitages ja immer von anfang an
gesagt dass wir auf keinen fall
kriegspartei werden dürfen sie erinnern
sich
ich habe hier eine rückkopplung
entschuldigung
habe mich an die diskussion über die
flugverbotszone wo wir klar gemacht
haben dass es das mit uns nicht geben
wird beides hätte bedeutet dass wir und
unsere nachbarn franzosen italiener
nato-partner in einem möglicherweise
luftkrieg mit den russen eingetreten
wäre er ist das keine neuerung nein wir
wollen nicht kriegspartei werden aber
wir sind natürlich partei und das
völkerrecht was den ukraine hat erlaubt
sich zur wehr zu setzen nachdem sie
überfallen worden sind alle auch uns war
ein völkerrechtlich die ukraine zu
unterstützen das machen wir jetzt sehr
deutlich ich räume wurden ein dass ich
als die verteidigungsministerin das
heute verkündet hat in ramstein woher
das treffen war der verteidigungs und
außenminister aller nato staaten war ich
angenehm überrascht ich darf das mal so
sagen weil wir unter teile ich die
meinung von meinem kollegen hofreiter
wir eben jetzt wirklich schauen müssen
es wird ja heftiger und deutlicher und
der expansionshunger von vladimir putin
kennt keine grenzen das ist schlimm
genug und deswegen finde ich das gut und
richtig dass wir das jetzt so machen wie
wir's machen er war der folie union hat
ja schon bisher die unterstützung der
ukraine mit hochwirksamen
gefechtsfeldwaffen gefordert die werden
ja jetzt offenbar geliefert das ist er
mit dem gepard
flugabwehr panzer ein anfang ziehen sie
jetzt eigentlich diesen entschluss
antrag im bundestag zurück mit dem sie
ja die ampel koalition unter druck
setzen wollten denn jetzt haben sie ja
schon einiges erreicht im gegenteil
möglicherweise gibt es ja jetzt sogar
einen gemeinsamen antrag man hört ja in
berlin heute abend dass dazu auch
gespräche zwischen der union und der
ampelkoalition laufen
ich bin ebenso wie die kollegin
strack-zimmermann
angenehm überrascht gewesen über diese
ankündigung und ich teile vollständig
die meinung die anton hofreiter hier
gesagt hat dass die ukraine von dem
westen insgesamt nachhaltig unterstützt
werden muss weil sie die freiheit und
die sicherheit europas weil sie die
friedensordnung europas verteidigt also
es geht in die richtige richtung sehr
spät aber immerhin ist jetzt doch eine
entscheidung gefallen dass begrüßten cdu
und csu das unterstützen wir
wir wollen gerne daran arbeiten dass wir
einen gemeinsamen antrag in den
deutschen bundestag einbringen die
ampelkoalition hat hierzu einen
umfassenden antrag vorgelegt zu dem wir
noch einige änderungen so und
ergänzungsvorschläge
haben und es sind jetzt für morgen
gespräche angeboten worden die wir
selbstverständlich annehmen die wir
führen werden wenn hier die
demokratische mitte des parlaments
zusammensteht und die bundesregierung
insgesamt unterstützt ist das gut und
ist das richtig
deutschland muss nach vorne kommen wenn
es um die unterstützung der ukraine geht
derzeit
hinken wir immer hinterher und das ist
nicht die rolle die wir einnehmen
sollten man muss immer wissen dass ganz
europa etwas argwöhnisch und auch
ängstlich schaut ob es nicht eine
deutsch-russische verständigung zu ihren
lasten gips und dem darf man kein
vorschub leisten sondern wir stehen an
der seite der freiheit wir stehen an der
seite unserer eu partner unserer
nato-partner sowieso aber wir stehen
eben auch an der seite so demokratisch
republikanischer staaten wie der ukraine
und auch der moldau und da müssen wir
jetzt weiter sehr wachsam sein und
zusammen stehen er war der vorlauf noch
nachfragen sie sagen dass im ausland
europäischen ausland der eindruck
entsteht es gebe hier eine
deutsch-russische ja wie auch immer
verständigung hinter dem rücken der
anderen länder glauben sie dass die
länder das immer noch glauben nach all
dem was jetzt passiert ist auch was die
ampel koalition jetzt auch beschließt in
sachen verteidigung der ukraine das war
immer noch irgendwie unter der
decke subkutan
deutschland und russland gemeinsame
sache machen so habe ich sie jetzt
zumindest das gerade verstanden
nein dort also gemeinsame sache würde
ich nicht sagen aber das ist doch
vollkommen klar dass wir aus dem
katastrophalen
hitler-stalin-pakt einfach ein
historisches erbe haben und wir müssen
natürlich auch sagen dass wir manche
warnung kriegen den vergangenen jahren
nicht so ernst genommen haben wie sie
von vielen osteuropäischen partnern auch
von manchen bei uns in der innenpolitik
gesagt worden sind ich räume das
jedenfalls für meine person und auch
früher die cdu ein dass wir dort dass
wir das kritisch zu überprüfen haben am
ende ist es schon so dass nord stream 2
ein gefährliches projekt gewesen ist das
jetzt gestoppt worden ist also eine
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit
kooperation mit russland
und das ist einfach ein punkt den man
jetzt sehen muss und die zögerliche
unterstützung deutschlands welches jahr
spät waffen geliefert hat und jetzt auch
spät viel später als viele andere
staaten bei den schweren waffen der
ukraine unter die arme greift das lässt
immer sehr schnell auch dort weitere
ängste entstehen aber ich räume ein oder
beziehungsweise ich freue mich darüber
ich unterstütze das auch das insgesamt
gesehen
die koalition und auch die
bundesregierung nicht nur in worten
sondern auch in taten an der seite haben
damit die diskussion dieser sendung
nicht vom thema abkommen sich jetzt nur
noch die feststellung machen es gab ja
auch eine ganze reihe von maßgeblichen
unions politikerinnen und politikern die
zum beispiel nach dem 2 ursprünglich
unterstützt haben eurofighter ist es
sinnvoll sagt ja der herr hofrat da ist
es sinnvoll das ist jetzt zwischen der
ampel koalition und der unionsfraktion
da eine gemeinsame entschließung gibt
gehen sie davon aus dass es soweit auch
kommt dass ich an dieser frage in einer
so wichtigen frage eben das parlament
nicht zerlegt wir sind ja wirklich ganz
außerordentliche situation es findet ein
angriffs- und vernichtungskrieg in
europa statt und wenn das ergebnis ein
gutes ist es natürlich absolut sinnvoll
wenn die demokratischen parteien
entsprechend gut zusammenarbeiten und
man sagt in so einer situation wo auch
von deutschland viel erwartet wird in
europa und es stimmt aufgrund gott der
energiepolitik der vergangenen jahre und
dem wo wir auch als deutschland mit
mittel- und osteuropäischen
bündnispartnern umgegangen präsentiert
von deutschland noch einmal mehr
erwartet und deshalb werden was gutes
dabei herauskommt ist es sinnvoll wenn
sie in diesem antrag wenn es einen
solchen antrag geben sollte zu stehen
oder was darf da nicht drin stehen damit
sie ihm zustimmen ich glaube so führten
keine gespräche aber man muss ja sehen
der antrag hin die union gestellt hatte
zog sich ausschließlich auf das thema
waren die foul ich glaube dass es
richtig ist einen antrag zu formulieren
die auch die politische die humanitäre
die finanzielle unterstützung an spricht
er da auch das thema zum beispiel
aufruft das durch den krieg gegen die
ukraine durch den handball street
erwarten auch horst nöte in afrika
ausgelöst wenn man sich um viele dinge
zu kümmern halter stehen diesem antrag
darin auch die korrekturen die bei der
energiepolitik notwendig sind werden da
angesprochen und ein solcher umfassender
antrag in der vernünftig ist und
gemeinsam beschlossen wir dann ist das
ein gutes signal an die öffentlichkeit
denn in fragen von krieg und frieden
verbietet sich meiner meinung nach das
kleine parteipolitische caro jedenfalls
wenn man das vermeiden kann sollte man
das vermeiden wenn wir einig sein wollen
in europa und mit unserer verbündeten
jenseits des atlantiks dann sollten wir
das auch zwischen demokratischen
parteien im deutschen bundestag ein
bekommen das ist jedenfalls unser wohl
schon deswegen bin ich zuversichtlich
dass wir am ende noch reinkriegen jemand
zu stemmen kann frau zimmermann wenn man
jetzt diese waffensysteme an die ukraine
liefert ist der grund ja der dass der
aggressor zurückgedrängt wird dass die
ukraine in die lage
versetzt wird oder nach wie vor versetzt
ist ein souveräner staat zu sein der
auch selbstständig und souverän handeln
kann dazu braucht es einen militärischen
erfolg der ukraine könnten sie den mann
definieren was ist aus ihrer sicht was
wäre ein militärischer erfolg mit hilfe
westlicher waffenlieferungen
als wäre ein unglaublich militärischer
erfolg die russische armee
zurückzudrängen wir dürfen ja nicht
vergessen dass die russische armee das
und die ukraine überfallen hat und davon
ausgegangen ist also putin ist davon
ausgegangen dass in wenigen tagen kiew
erreicht nicht nur das an der auf der
straße die leute ihn zu jubeln sondern
aus seinen wenigen tagen in kiew ankommt
das ist eben nicht gelungen wir sind
heute im tag 1 61 62 das heißt die
ukraine hat sich wehren können aber eben
auch mit militärischer unterstützung
denn putin hat sehr schnell die in
klinischen flotte und auch die luftwaffe
außer kraft gesetzt wenn es also der
ukraine gelänge den den vorlauf der
russen zu stoppen den weiter aus wir das
schon mal ein sehr großer erfolg
am besten natürlich am wichtigsten wäre
ist wenn die ukraine ist schaffen wir
dass die russen sich zurückziehen das
ist natürlich schwer weil die russen
einfach klasse
da druck machen aber mit entsprechender
unterstützung seitens der europäer wir
sind ja nicht allein das muss man sagen
wir sind ja nicht die einzigen die
militärische an der seite der ukraine
stehen sondern eben auch die
europäischen partner die nato staaten
dann wäre das ein großer erfolg allein
den angriff abzuwehren dass damit hat
keiner gerechnet ich glaube wir alle die
wir hier sitzen haben wir den ersten
tagen nicht im entferntesten daran
gedacht dass fast zwei monate später die
ukraine immer noch diesen kampf besteht
wo frage jetzt geht der amerikanische
verteidigungsminister lloyd austin ja
eigentlich weiter hat gestern gesagt es
gehe auch darum russland so zu schwächen
militärisch zu schwächen
damit es künftig solche aggressionen und
solche kriegsverbrechen die aus diesen
aggressionen resultierende ukraine nicht
mehr geben kann haben sie eine
vorstellung wie das aussehen könnte also
russland quasi die angriffs fähigkeit zu
nehmen ein land das jahr hoch gerüstet
ist und dass jede menge atomwaffen hat
ich glaube es geht hier nicht um
atomwaffen sondern es stellt sich die
frage ob der
imperialismus der position art zu seinem
ende kommt niemand dafür einzelnen
vergessen putin hat bereits 2007
angekündigt das russische reich wieder
errichten zu wollen er hat daraufhin
georgien angegriffen er hat die ukraine
2014 angegriffen er hat die ukraine
jetzt wieder angegriffen er droht damit
und das ist sehr glaubhaft wenn man sich
anschaut die republik moldau anzugreifen
und man muss deutlich machen dass auf
der einen seite mit sanktionen die darf
man aber auf gar keinen fall vergessen
bei der debatte um die waffen und auf
der anderen seite mit der
verteidigungsfähigkeit der ukraine
deutlich zu machen putin dein system
wird nicht erfolgreich sein mit dem ziel
das russische imperium so wie er es sich
vorstellt wo unmengen jetzt unabhängige
selbständige staaten dazu können wieder
zu errichten auch in polen gibt es
richtig ernsthaft angst dass putin dass
russland polen angreift im baltikum und
ich glaube so ist es zu verstehen dass
russland zurück kehrt in den kreis der
staaten was unter boris jelzin schon mal
der fall war wo man vernünftig
miteinander agieren kann ich gesagt ich
glaube gegen putin waren wir alle zu
naiv nämlich im grunde hat das
angekündigt was er vorhat er liegt
vielleicht aus taktischen gründen fast
jeden tag aber ist ein strategisches
ziel hat er uns eigentlich offen auf den
tisch clique wollen laut hin möglich was
ich sagen oder geht es wenn man
irgendwann mal in der zukunft eine
verständigung in russland geht das nur
ohne putin das mag ich jetzt nicht
beurteilen aber es gibt im grunde zwei
dinge die putin extrem fürchtet das eine
ist die demokratie weil es nämlich seine
oligarchische kleptokratie unter druck
setzt das zweite was er will ist die
errichtung des russischen
wiedererrichtung des russischen reiches
es kann durchaus sein da er selber auch
in kleptow grad ist wenn er erkennt dass
er das nicht erreichen kann dass er dann
zurück weicht
kann man auch mit putin noch verhandeln
sie gehören zu denjenigen die sagen die
diplomatie darf man nicht vergessen bei
allen militärischen aktivitäten ist das
überhaupt denke ich rede jetzt nicht von
russland und ich rede von putin oder von
dem regime putin ist es überhaupt
denkbar von einer
waffenstillstandsverhandlungen mal
abgesehen
da mit mit dem regime putin noch
irgendwie zu einer einigung zu kommen
also die politik von regime change
sozusagen ist keine die
erfolgversprechend ist und man darf sich
auch nicht täuschen dass man dem
wunschdenken anheim fällt die zustimmung
für putin in russland auch wenn man den
zahlen des dollar ist größer als man es
lieb sein kann und auch die
unterstützung in anderen teilen der welt
ist größer als uns lieb sein kann und
deswegen glaube ich darf man es aus
militärischer auch nicht verhängen wir
müssen kriege enden am ende immer mit
politischen verständigung und sie müssen
so bald wie möglich enden denn das ist
unsägliches leid und zerstörung und
vertreibung und flucht was damit
verbunden ist und all die anderen
probleme gefahren na ja auch und
deswegen glaube ich muss man vorsichtig
sein mit denen man kann sich das
wünschen aber vorsichtig sein mit den
prognosen russland ist die zweitgrößte
atommacht der welt und deswegen waren ja
die prämissen die wir hatten in der
unterstützung der ukraine dass man auf
der einen seite alles tut was man kann
um der ukraine zu helfen damit putin
nicht erfolgreich ist mit seinem krieg
dass man zweiter das immer immer
deutsche alleingänge vermieden werden
dass wir gemeinsam handeln aber der
bundeskanzler ist auch artikel 56 dauer
vereidigt schaden vom deutschen volk
abzuwenden
deswegen
muss ich schon aussagen finde ich manche
betrachten die ich so höre wo über
atomkrieg und sowas leichtfertig daher
geredet wird ganz schön leichtfertig
denn was wir uns in keiner weise
erlauben kann ist dass wir ein
flächenbrand in europa bekommen dass der
krieg ausgeweitet wird und man trifft
viele bürger in diesen tagen bürgerinnen
und bürger die einen sagen ältere zum
beispiel den krieg noch als kinder
erlebt haben dass sie angst wieder haben
davor dass der krieg deutschland
erreichen können dass dem auch ein teil
dessen was wir erreichen müssen dass
dieser krieg sich nicht ausweitet
sondern das putting gestoppt hat schon
einem anderen betrieb redet vor allen
dingen auch olaf scholz und verbreitet
damit vielleicht nicht unbedingt auch
ruhe und gelassenheit
nun ist es ja er hat nicht vor allen
dingen davon sondern er spricht davon
dass wir nicht wie in syrien oder im
libanon oder im irak und afghanistan
ein solches land
als kriegsführenden partei haben sondern
die zweitgrößte atommacht der welt und
das regime gefällt uns nicht wir werden
manches gerne ändern der gehört nach den
haag putin mit den kriegsverbrechen die
er begangen hat aber die hoffnung dass
da bald regime change stattfindet und
rostands klein beigibt die habe ich
ehrlich gesagt nicht und deswegen ist
realistischer realistischer blick auf
die verhältnisse dort schon auch
angebracht erwartet wohl ein change in
russland von außen ist undenkbar dass
wird tatsächlich zum dritten weltkrieg
führen
möglich wäre es ja eigentlich nur ein
wechsel des regimes von ein sturz des
regimes von innen das wird aber wenn
überhaupt sehr sehr lange dauern glauben
sie dass wir hier eigentlich lernen
müssen dass wir auf lange sicht mit
russland wahrscheinlich auch mit putin
dann eben nicht zu einer verständigung
kommen werden das ist quasi auf lange
sicht eine politische eiszeit gibt die
man nicht in jahren sondern vielleicht
sogar einen jahrzehnten rechnen muss
ja ich bin der auffassung gehe anton
hofreiter auch geäußert habe dass wir
das wahrscheinlich putin unterschätzt
haben wir sind eigentlich schon länger
in einer eiszeit drin und müssen dass
mehr realisieren und was macht man in so
einer eiszeit dann macht man realpolitik
und verteidigt das was einem wichtig ist
und das ist die friedensordnung
europas und das setzt voraus dass
staaten souveränen sind und dass ihre
grenzen unantastbar sind das muss man
wie in dieser konkreten situation eben
auch mit waffen für uns heißt das mit
waffen unterstützung gewährleisten und
deswegen glaube ich ganz realistisch
betrachtet weil sie nach den zielen
fragten müssen wir uns jetzt noch auf
einen etwas längeren konflikt einstellen
das ziel muss selbstverständlich sein
dass die souveränität der ukraine
vollständig wieder hergestellt wird das
heißt dass sämtliche russische truppen
das land verlassen ein anderes ergebnis
ist jedenfalls von vornherein
unsererseits nicht zu akzeptieren und
alles andere muss die ukraine am ende
auch souverän
aushandeln dafür müssen wir einstehen
und wir müssen
für die zeit danach die ukraine und alle
anderen staaten auch entsprechend
ausstatten dass sie sich verteidigen
können dazu wird ja unter anderem auch
gehören dass zwei skandinavische länder
schweden und finnland jetzt darüber
nachdenken sehr ernsthaft die nato
einzutreten ich glaube das wäre auch ein
richtiger schritt dass sie seinen
schritt und wäre ein schritt zu mehr
sicherheit in europa zu stabilität weil
ja ein defensives bündnis sind und weil
wir lernen mussten weil die ukraine ja
bitter lernen musste dass nicht
verteidigungsfähigkeit und der umstand
dass man keine bündnispartner hat
bedauerlicherweise dazu führt dass man
einem angriff zunächst einmal ausgesetzt
ist und ich glaube diesen diesen weg
müssen wir jetzt konsequent
weiterführen und dabei auch risiken
selbstverständlich eingehen ich fand die
äußerung des bundeskanzlers zum thema
atom krieg nicht besonders klug
selbstverständlich muss alles vermieden
werden dass so etwas geschieht aber wir
dürfen doch niemals den eindruck
erweckten als dass wir von der bloßen
drohung russlands oder putins dass es zu
einem atomkrieg kommen könnte schon
motiviert werden zurückzuweichen denn
wenn das der fall wäre dann wäre ja auch
schon die frage gestellt ob wir bereit
sind das baltikum zu verteidigen wenn es
dort eine verletzung der staatlichen
souveränität gebe also da rate ich sehr
dazu dass wir diese diskussion nicht
weiterführen sondern dass wir dazu
stehen dass abschreckung funktioniert
und dass wir auch bereit sind in solchen
konfliktsituationen
auch die europäische freiheit und
sicherheit zu verteidigen frau
zimmermann war es so klug vom
bundeskanzler sozusagen dieses szenario
eines möglichen atomkrieg zu bemühen
auch um seine position zu vertreten in
den letzten tagen und wochen heute hat
ja der russische außenminister sergej
lawrow auf diesen bald eigentlich mehr
oder minder aufgenommen in dem er gesagt
hat er möchte durch auch keinen
atomkrieg aber
möglicherweise wollen dass andere das
kann man nicht ausschließen dass dieses
narrativ das eigentlich ja putin die
welt gesetzt hat wir können uns auch
atomar wären jetzt von olaf scholz
aufgenommen worden ist und er damit
möglicherweise das spiel vor putin
betrieben hat
also dass diese situation sehr
gefährlich ist die frage glaub ich
stellt sich nicht ich fand es nicht so
geschickt das liegt aber auch daran dass
natürlich ist nicht nur ein krieg
herrscht damit drucken sondern auch ein
kommunikations krieg und dieses szenario
aufzubauen was könnte noch alles sein
das verursacht natürlich große ängste in
der tat auch bei den menschen das
erreicht uns ja auch und diesen ball
aufzugreifen und die geschichte
sozusagen weiter zu spielen also in
anführungszeichen halte ich auch für ein
fehler wir dürfen uns bei aller
ernsthaftigkeit die frage stellt sich ja
nicht sollten uns eben nicht dieses
narratives bedienen denn das einzige was
putin bzw abwurf eben erreichen will
dass wir das eben doch sich so breit
macht in unseren köpfen dass wir eben
doch zögern wehrhaft zu sein wir dürfen
ja nicht vergessen wir leben in einer
werte basierten ordnung und wenn wir da
zurückweichen dann wird das für 500
millionen europäern europäer bedeuten
dass wenn diese ordnung zerstört ist
dass der stärkere sieg also der bde
stärkere waffen hat er die größere
truppen hat und auch die größere
dreistigkeit eben andere die
ländergrenzen die territoriale
integrität nicht zu akzeptieren und
darum geht es jetzt es ist ein kampf
nicht nur um grund und boden sondern es
geht auch darum und lehrte und insofern
kann ich mir übrigens wenn ich das noch
anschließender überhaupt nicht
vorstellen dass man sich noch jemals mit
putin an einen tisch setzt denn dass er
was er steht zurecht sagte hoffentlich
sich in den haag irgendwann wieder
finden und in der wiederfindet um sich
vor gericht zu stellen aber mit so einem
der nicht in anführungszeichen nur gegen
soldaten kämpfen sondern zivilisten
tötet geburtskliniken bombardiert andere
hofreiter und ich die in der west
ukraine waren hat ja gesehen was dort
angerichtet wurde weit im westen
dass das der kinder entführt werden all
diese grausamkeiten kann man ja nicht
das kann man ja nicht hinnehmen und
sagen jetzt sprechen wir weiter also
selbst wenn es zu einem frieden kommt
was eine gute nachricht wäre muss
erstens die ukraine für sich selbst
entscheiden wie ein solcher frieden
auszusehen hat ich halte das nicht für
unsere aufgabe das ist die integrität
dieses landes das muss das ukrainische
volk wissen aber eins ist klar dass
putin kann nicht mehr auf augenhöhe mit
uns sprechen halte ich für völlig
unmöglich und natürlich können wir kein
regime change hinbekommen da das ist
schon richtig aber man muss klar machen
da kann man nicht business as usual und
da sind dann halt mal paar tausend
menschen umgekommen 1 das muss klar sein
auch für das russische volk wenn wir auf
lange sicht wieder eine normalität
kommen wollen und ich glaube das wollen
wir weil nach wie vor stimmt es kann
frieden nur in europa geben mit russland
sehen wir ja gerade dann definitiv nicht
mit linien putin und seiner clique ich
sage mal ganz kurz war sie jetzt auch
schon gerade reagiert haben auf die
äußerung zu olaf scholz aber es war ja
eine von drei begründungen für euch live
shows bisher
hochwirksame gefechtsfeldwaffen vulgo
schwere waffen eben nicht in die ukraine
zu liefern ein weltumspannender die
gefahr eines weltumspannenden krieges
dass wir die waffen selbst brauchen um
aus dem bestand der bundeswehr und dass
die ukraine dadurch nicht in kurzer zeit
ausgebildet werden können jetzt gelten
diese argumente aber plötzlich seit
heute morgen nicht mehr dass das nicht
zutreffen aber ich will dich vor allem
dagegen wehren dass hier behauptet wird
würden negative von einem putin
übernommen die bundesrepublik die
bürgerinnen bürger erwarten von ihrem
bundeskanzler dass er genauso wie der
amerikanische präsident und wieder
französisch weil sind die uns keinerlei
zweifel gelassen haben dass das nicht in
frage kommen kann dass die nato
involviert wird und mit der gleichen
begründung ist auch weder kampfpanzer
noch kämpfen zeuge liefern wenn wir von
schweren waffen reden reden wir darüber
gepanzerte fahrzeuge die menschen
transportieren und wenn sie mal hören
was der französische präsident in
interviews gesagt wofür in die roten
linien sind dann ist das sehr viel
schärfer noch gewesen als dass olaf
scholz gesagt aber klar ist dass beide
ihre bevölkerung noch sagen müssen wir
wissen sehr wohl wir haben es hier mit
einer nuklearmacht zu tun und das heißt
eben auch äußerste vorsicht und dass man
eben nicht die eigene bevölkerung der
sorge aussetzt es könnte einen krieg
geben denn einen nuklearkrieg in der
heutigen zeit heißt das alles vernichtet
würde und das sind nicht mehr aktive den
mann auf den leim geht und schon gleich
gar nichts was man tut um sich erpressen
zu lassen sondern dass die bürgerin
bewahren ich will das mal sehr deutlich
sagen abräumen können sagen was sie
wollen haben das recht sich zu äußern
wie sie wollen aber es ist was eines
forderungen aufzustellen und es ist
etwas anderes der bevölkerung auch
klarzumachen dass was da hieß es sei
tödlich ist eher die form von
besonnenheit die die bürgerinnen und
bürger erwarten von jemandem im
kanzleramt sitzt und dafür
verantwortlich ist dass es am ende die
sicherheit auch unseres landes
gewährleistet ist dass ein bisschen noch
etwas anderes und deswegen wie ich das
eher nachteilig verteidigung und die
reaktion als empörung sind auch sehr
eindeutig dass sie das sehr zu schätzen
wissen ich habe gelesen heute gab es
eine umfrage zu der frage finden sie
eigentlich dem bundeskanzler zögerlich
oder finden sie teilen sie die haltung
die der bundeskanzler und ich glaube es
waren es zwei drittel die gesagt haben
sie unterstützen diese haltung das
bestätigt mich darin zu sagen was
erwarten sie vom bundeskanzler und die
partei der der bundeskanzler angehört
unterstützte gut dass der kanzler
zögerlich sei und möglicherweise nicht
für diese vorhaben ja unter anderem von
ihnen frau statt zimmermann auch von
ihnen war hoch weiter wenn man sich
jetzt diese diskussion den letzten
wochen ansieht wie sich das alles immer
wieder verändert hat gerade in der frage
der unterstützung der ukraine
2 die position der spd erst sollten gar
keine waffen in spannungsgebiete
geliefert werden das in kriegsgebiete
das hat allerdings auch ihre partei
zunächst mal vertreten dann schutzhelm
und schutzwesten dann leichte waffen
dann panzerhaubitzen dann vielleicht
noch waffen aus ehemaligen nva beständen
die woanders in zwischenlagern jetzt
kommen wir langsam richtung schwere
waffen in der umgangssprache nennt man
so etwas salamitaktik wird man sie dass
der spd vorwerfen dass sie immer wieder
erst nach großem druck nachgegeben hat
und dass dann auch das zu uns stehen ich
keinen diskussion innerhalb der ampel
koalition geführt hat ich glaube es
bringen wir uns überhaupt nicht sich im
nachhinein dinge vorzuwerfen natürlich
wünscht man sich in so einer schweren
krise dass dinge schneller laufen aber
es läuft ja sozusagen jetzt eine
richtige richtung und das ist einfach
erst bei gut aber natürlich muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen dass dann
insbesondere der druck aus dem
europäischen ausland mit dazu
beigetragen hat und bei mir als europa
ausschuss vorsitzender ist schon sehr
sehr viel besorgnis angekommen gerade
von unseren bündnispartnern und
bündnispartnern um in deutschland einen
alleingang macht indem es einfach sowohl
bei sanktionen
am anfang war es wird dann bei energie
zu zögerlich ist als auch bei der
unterstützung der ukraine zu zögerliches
und diese sorge war bei unseren
bündnispartnern groß und ist es zum teil
immer noch und ich man wenn man mit dem
baltikum spricht wenn man mit polen
spricht wenn man mit weiteren
osteuropäischen er spricht wenn man in
der ukraine ist dann schauen die das
sehr genau hin und was gerade in der
ukraine am stärksten aufstößt es sind so
paternalistische argumente
marie agnes strack zimmermann und
michael oder nicht wir waren eine kleine
und die nehmen unsere debatte sehr genau
wahr und so argumente wie die können ja
mit unseren waffen nicht umgehen also
das finden die sehr abstrus weil sie
sagen seit sieben wochen verteidigen wir
hier freiheit und demokratie für ganz
europa und unsere militärs ist voll und
ganz bewusst dass sie nicht von heute
auf morgen mit westlichen waffen umgehen
können deswegen wünschen sie sich ja
dass die zeitnahe geliefert werden um
ihre soldaten dazu trainieren also
gerade diese paternalistische
argumentation kommt sehr schlechter
vorschlag zimmermann die osteuropäer die
osteuropäischen nato staaten sind ja
nach wie vor sehr misstrauisch gegenüber
deutschland das hat gründe die haben wir
ja schon angesprochen die haltung
gegenüber der ukraine aus dem 2 und so
weiter diese sie haben den bundeskanzler
auch kritisiert wegen seiner art zu
führen und auch seiner mangelnde
entschlossenheit dass er nach der rede
im bundestag eben nicht zur tat
geschritten ist das was jetzt passiert
ist gibt ihnen das hoffnung dass
olaf scholz das macht was sie von ihm
auch erwarten zu führen klare
leitplanken einzuziehen auch klare
klartext zu reden im land selbst auch
gegenüber den bündnispartnern damit
deutschland das vertrauen zurückgewinnt
dass es braucht
also zuerst einmal herr köhler haben wir
ja einen sehr guten koalitionsvertrag
geschmiedet in der 8 wo ist natürlich
kein kapitel gab was machen wir bei
krieg insofern wurden wir wir waren noch
nicht mal 100 tage im amt mit dem
schlimmsten konfrontiert was ich eben
hat keiner in dieser dimension
vorstellen können ja ich habe den
bundeskanzler kritisiert weil es ja sehr
viele ministerien involviert des
verteidigungsministeriums
außenministerien das
wirtschaftsministerium spielt auch eine
große rolle weil es bezeichnen muss er
wenn waffen geliefert werden und da hat
mir in der tat die führung dein leben
gefehlt und damit hier keine
missverständnisse aufkommen
es geht gar nicht darum dass man in
irgendeiner weise die atomare gefahr nie
irgendwie kleinreden will und dass wir
einen besonderen bundeskanzler brauchen
aber besonnenheit heißt natürlich auch
dinge zu erklären denn die bevölkerung
habe natürlich gesehen was passiert
insofern schaue ich positiv in die
zukunft ich halte es für eine sehr kluge
entscheidung
der bundesregierung jetzt auch schwerere
waffen zu schicken weil sie gerade eher
kühler so aufgeführt haben dass man erst
dass eine diskutiert hat oder das andere
diskutiert hat das lag natürlich auch
daran dass im militärischen sich eine
lage ändert und wenn sich eine lage
ändert muss sich auch die einsicht bzw
die situation für uns die wir
entscheidungen zu treffen haben ändern
und anpassen deswegen fairerweise muss
ich sagen vor sieben wochen war keiner
so weit wie heute sind aber angesichts
der dramatik angesichts der ermordeten
zivilisten hat sich die situation eben
erschwert also ich schaue positiv in die
zukunft wäre angesichts des dramas in
der ukraine vielleicht nicht dass die
falte ist falsche würden aber ich glaube
es ist ein richtiges zeichen im elton
rammstein haben sich die minister und
die ministerin heute getroffen auch 1
sehr sehr starkes zeichen dass die nato
zusammen steht ein wichtiges zeichen
dass schweden und finnland mit
ziemlicher wahrscheinlichkeit den antrag
stellen mit offenen armen in die nato
aufgenommen zu werden all das hatte
wladimir putin ja nicht kommen sehen er
dachte die nato ist hirntot er dachte
die eu streitet sich sowieso nur kann
auch mit der eu gar nichts anfangen für
ihn gibt es diese machtblöcke usa china
russland
er hätte nie gedacht dass neutrale
staaten um sich der nato jetzt zuwenden
hätte die kampfkraft der ukraine hat er
völlig unterschätzt also da kommt jetzt
eine menge zusammen und ich glaube er
ist gerade weil er die diskussion hier
auch mit verfolgt dass das was ich wurde
auch einige als zögerlich empfunden
haben dass das jetzt umgesetzt wird ist
glaube ich auch für wladimir putin eine
große überraschung dass deutschland sagt
so wir machen auf der einen seite den
ringtausch also osteuropäer schicken
ihre waffen und wir kompensieren dass
mit dem beruf männern die dann später zu
laufen und auf der anderen seite dass
wir heute bereits sind auch andere auch
direkt waffen zu liefern das ist ein
schon ein paradigmenwechsel
es ist richtig wir haben alle gesagt in
krisengebiete wollen wir keine waffen
schicken aber angesichts des dramas ist
es jetzt der richtige zeitpunkt gut ist
ob es war marco mader von der hirntoten
nato gesprochen hat und noch eine ganz
kurze korrektur mein nachname lautet auf
die norddeutsche form von köhler nämlich
keller mit deutschland bin ich noch mal
bei herrn wadephul erwartet
steigt sie aber man hat es gerade
angesprochen heute die konferenz in
ramstein das wurde ja auch über die
nachkriegsordnung gesprochen also was
passiert eigentlich nach dem krieg der
ukraine deutschland soll ja da als
führungsmacht auch vorangehen die usa
werden militärisch helfen aber die
politischen neuordnung in europa die
muss ja auch unterführung deutschland
und frankreich stattfinden
glauben sie dass das gelingen wird in
dieser konstellation
dass also deutschland da auch eine
führungsrolle nimmt übernimmt in als
europäische führungsmacht nach diesem
krieg
das wäre sehr wünschenswert ich sehe
dass zum jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht und
ich kann den bundeskanzler nur
auffordern mit dem wiedergewählten
französischen präsidenten makro hier die
initiative zu ergreifen
ich möchte darüber hinaus die erwartung
zum ausdruck bringen meiner fraktion
dass der bundeskanzler in dieser woche
zu denen entscheidungen die getroffen
worden sind und auch zu dem verkehr was
sie angesprochen haben was jetzt vor uns
liegt auch das wort ergreift also wir
haben den bundeskanzler sehr wenig zu
dieser
schwierigen internationalen lage gehört
und ich glaube in der jetzigen situation
wäre es angemessen wenn der
bundeskanzler im deutschen bundestag der
jetzt auch wie wir anfangs diskutiert
haben über einen gemeinsamen antrag und
auch über eine gesamtwürdigung der
situation diskutieren wird wenn der
bundeskanzler das wort ergreifen würde
und auch dazu etwas sagen würde man uns
gelegenheit geben würde mit ihnen
gemeinsam zu diskutieren
deutschland muss sehen dass wir
gefordert sind als das zentrale land als
die stärkste volkswirtschaft als das
land mit den meisten nachbarn in europa
das wir gemeinsam mit frankreich auch in
der jetzigen situation
gefordert sind
den europäischen faktor einzubringen und
hier in der tat wie sie gesagt haben
eine führungsrolle einzunehmen das sind
zurzeit wieder einmal wie fast immer in
jeder kritischen situation seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg die usa gewesen es ist
ja schon ehrlich gesagt etwas eigenartig
dass die vereinigten staaten von amerika
in deutschland in ramstein zwar auf
einmal amerikanischen stützpunkt aber in
deutschland alle anderen partner zu
einer ukraine konferenz einladen zu
einer konferenz wo die hilfsaktion für
die zukunft organisiert und geplant
werden und dass die usa sagen und jetzt
treffen wir uns jeden monat und sprechen
darüber was fehlt noch wo können wir
noch nachbessern um deutschland zu den
eingeladenen gehört und dabei ist nein
wir müssen in eine aktive rolle
hineinwachsen wir müssen diejenigen sein
die hier gestalten und die endlich das
tun was wir in vielen sonntagsreden wenn
es um europa und europäische zukunft
geht immer wieder sagen dass wir selber
das heft des handelns in die hand nehmen
wollen dass wir eigenständig werden
wollen als europäer und ich kann noch
mal sagen wenn wir ein bisschen ein paar
jahre zurückdenken als präsident trump
nach in amerika regiert hat da war uns
doch allen bewusst dass wir europäischer
und selbstständiger werden müssen man
muss jetzt nicht dass worte souveränität
übernehmen was was präsident mag rang
gewählt hat das ist sehr sehr viel aber
es fehlt an dem deutschen willen
gemeinsam mit anderen den europäischen
faktor auszumachen und das wünsche ich
mir jetzt sehr von der bundesregierung
sie hatte ich jedenfalls unsere
unterstützung gefühl gut jetzt ist es ja
so der bundeskanzler der glaube ich
morgen früh bei agnes marie agnes strack
zimmermann eine einigung im
verteidigungsausschuss das findet jetzt
glaub ich am 11 mai statt am donnerstag
nicht im bundestag über den antrag
abgestimmt wird da ist er in japan der
vater muss es auch symbolische
handlungen anrede und entschuldigt jetzt
war die
erwartete von ganz kurz hofreiter muss
es da aber möglicherweise auch mehr
symbolpolitik des bundeskanzlers geben
zum beispiel dass er demnächst nach kiew
reist nicht nur nach japan
das ist etwas wo ich dem bundeskanzler
überhaupt keine ratschläge geben will
das muss ja einfach schließlich selbst
entscheiden ich fand sehr beeindruckend
in die ukraine zu reizen wir haben uns
wie gesagt da auch mit verwundeten
soldaten
getroffen von mich besonders
beeindruckend war wie genau die
abgeordneten der ukraine für unsere
debatte bescheid wissen und wie sehr sie
darauf achten was wir debattieren
und ich glaube was hat uns einfach
wirklich klar sein muss es wie groß die
erwartungen an deutschland sind also was
von uns erwartet
was von uns gefordert wird und ich kann
es auch sehr verstehen denn wir sind mit
abstand zwischen das wirtschaftsstärkste
land innerhalb der europäischen union
und das glaube ich muss uns einfach
stärker bewusst sein in deutschland und
wie gesagt wir haben jetzt glück dass
beiden
präsident dass man stelle sich vor in
dieser krise wäre tram präsident und
deswegen ich finde das wort europäische
souveränität richtig und es wäre einfach
sehr wünschenswert und im
koalitionsvertrag der ampel steht doch
viel spannendes drin wenn wir in den
nächsten jahren viele schritte ton in
richtung europäisches verwendet er ist
das ein großes problem dieses
zeitfenster dieses geringe zeitfenster
europäische souveränität dass anton
hofreiter gerade angesprochen hat auch
die frage ob waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine wirklich noch wirksam werden
können ob es die dem land noch helfen
kann ich weiß dass nicht ich glaube man
kann das nicht auf diese frage verengung
ich bin ein bisschen erstaunt über die
bemerkung des kollegen war davor
deutschland ist sehr wohl in der führung
ich finde die enge abstimmung gerade mit
joe biden und mit immer nur meckern sehr
sinnvoll die letzten 16 jahre ist die
kanzlerin angela merkel wir sind jetzt
gerade mal etwas mehr als 100 tage im
amt deutschland hat übrigens zu
unterstützen der ukraine mehr getan um
man die tiere wirtschaftlich finanziell
als fast alle anderen staaten und das
sollte man auch nicht ruto
inlandsprodukt dass deutschland
insgesamt ist es so dass deutschland
eine ganze menge gitarre von deutschland
wird auch viel erwartet wir handeln
gemeinsam mit unseren freunden in paris
oder washington das ist gut die
beziehungen waren lange nicht mehr so
gut wie sie jetzt zu den usa das ist gut
und richtig so und insofern finde ich
die kritik der neuen opposition ein
bisschen schnell nach 16 jahren angela
merkel aber es ist denn so er war davon
kann ganz sicher sein dass diese
führungsrolle wahr genommen werden
in fragen der unterstützung der ukraine
wir sind kanzlerpartei und wissen so zu
sagen welche verantwortung auf urlaubs-
lastet und wir sind ganz sicher dass die
bevölkerung das richtig von den übrigen
die entscheidung im bundessicherheitsrat
werden getroffen gemeinsam von olaf
scholz annalena baerbock und christian
gentner das funktioniert da ganz gut und
das anderen parlament muss man aushalten
auch wenn es ein bisschen rauer all das
werden wir bei phoenix ganz genau
beobachten nicht nur im parlament
sondern ich auch in der phoenix runde
ich bedanke mich bei marie agnes strack
zimmermann bei johann wadephul und hier
im studio bei anton hofreiter und bei
ralf stegner bitte
entschuldigen sie dass ich
bei der nächsten sendung
das leben alles klar nur als hinweis von
dir vielen dank liebe zuschauer morgen
in der phoenix runde
der das thema nicht nur ein schöner
problem die spd und russland wir werden
einiges vertiefen was wir jetzt heute
schon besprochen haben bei diesem thema
jetzt wird königs der tag mit thomas
bade unter anderem darin die
pressekonferenz zu beratungen über die
unterstützung der ukraine am randstein
auch darüber haben wir schon gesprochen
jetzt noch etwas ausführlicher mit dem
us amerikanischen verteidigungsminister
und unserer verteidigungsministerium
diese zuschauer live zuschauer bleiben
sie bei uns
[Musik]